okay fine
i get it probably legally have to pay
tribute to lucasfilm and you
paid for this fancy star wars logo thing
it takes forever and it's a bit over the
top but now that we've got that out of
the way another logo for clone wars
it's not even the show i mean i know
this is a spin-off but do we really need
and here comes the logo for the
actual show title because god forbid
someone is watching that doesn't know
what
show they clicked on 40 seconds ago but
fine you did your thing and we finally
got through it and at least you won't
add yet another title for the title of
the episode after damn it
push to the brink trying to disguise
your blatant expositional narration by
pretending it's some sort of old-timey
cinema newsreel kind of thing just for
trying to sneak a bias i'm adding a sin
for the narration
exposition news entertainment and the
death of cinema
also this section is meant to clear
things up before launching this new
series
but really i'm just more confused
combined with a sneaking suspicion that
nothing will be cleared up by the end of
the next 70 minutes
led by jedi master deppa baloba depa
blabba am i the only one who thinks star
wars names feel like someone's just
trying to make up rhymes for a 90s
hip-hop
wish it was a little bit taller wish it
was a bala wish i had a girl who looked
good i would call uh wish i had a jedi
and a hat with a bat and called
babalaba history should think more
strategically about communication
why scream fire for all to hear when you
can make a robot noise and your enemy
would be none the wiser of your
intentions
uh where are they caleb
trust me using trust me as an answer to
an important question in a life or death
struggle
camping hey clanker
hey bobby you really think we need our
battle droids to have personalities on
the battlefield
of course then when stuff happens they
can make funny statements it'll be
hilarious
damn it bobby not everything has to be
an homage to the three stooges we needed
those things like yesterday
[ __ ] you frank i'm an artist
ah yes because the best way to ensure
that you won't topple off the side of
the cliff with the ship is to jump on
top of it and roll over it instead of
stepping to the side watching your team
in action was the fun i know this fpga
cameo as young caleb doom is fun and all
but that 45 year old voice does not go
with that teenage face and whatever the
uncanny valley is for sound
this character has set up residence
there you ready for this
we move fast the bad batch acts as
though the kid hasn't seen the move
before when in actuality caleb was the
one to bring them to the fight
very few of these shots blabba's
blocking are even gonna hit her and
these clone troopers are shooting at
point-blank range
starting to wonder if it maybe was the
stormtroopers that went to the clone
trooper school of aiming at things
what what just happened you watched a
jedi get gunned down while you were
close enough to help out
that's what i mean caleb seems to be
doing pretty well against two foes you'd
think his jedi master would have been
able to take out the clone troopers that
attacked her earlier running with your
lightsaber activated
and i know some of the experienced jedi
do it but you're still a padawan caleb
and not running with dangerous things in
your hand is like the first page of
things jedi parents have to say
it's right up there with don't sit too
close to the tv and where did that womp
rat come from and why did you just put
it in your mouth
person being chased runs into a cliff
and must decide whether or not to jump
cliche
no leaping with an active lightsaber
young man if you do not shape up
i will turn this speeder around right
now damn that's gorgeous and symbolic
too
some of the best modern star wars
material is on the animated side of
things
and that deserves a sin off how is this
convenient
let me count the ways it's convenient
that the jedi was somehow still holding
this lightsaber when killed
it's convenient that whoever took care
of the body left the saber in their hand
despite it being a fairly decent
collector's item and probably worth a
pretty penny on spacebook marketplace
it's convenient that the jedi was
left-handed it's convenient that at this
very moment that hand decided to jostle
loose
and it's convenient that whatever
species of jedi this is apparently
doesn't experience any kind of rigor
mortis that would have kept the saber
firmly in place
they manipulated pre-existing
aberrations in our dna
resulting in your brute strength cross
has sharp shooting skills
hunters enhanced senses and my
exceptional mind
this text position of each member's
abilities is so unnecessarily specific
they might as well just cut to character
sheets so i could see their modifiers
the damage you sustained on skakomina
that's it no more names or places or
people
or food or games or french new wave
cinema or whatever the hell you guys are
talking about
my name's omega i was wondering when you
guys would come back
and i'm wondering for the love of kiwi
why a star wars character would have a
distinct dialect from an island on a
planet that is apparently a long time in
the future in a galaxy far far away
unless you're saying there's a nebu
zealand in this universe and they
specifically cloned her with that
dialect in mind in which case tell
yourself whatever you want to sleep at
night but i've got a job to do
you're climbforth99 people keep saying
this clone force 99 thing like i'm
supposed to know what it means
i'm sorry was i supposed to do homework
before jumping into this you could get
arrested for doing that kind of stuff
around here in fact i think it's
considered our lone felony
felony good to see they were able to use
the cg rendering of tarkin from rogue
one without having to make a single
adjustment
smart and efficient at some point during
this meeting i realized how
frustratingly bright it is
can you imagine trying to concentrate in
an illuminated room like this
how are his pupils not pinpricks right
now i like to blow things up
because i like to blow things up audio
of michael bay responding to studio
notes somehow makes it into the episode
check it out the defect squads got
themselves a new recruit
considering zero other clones have
stopped to mock the bad batch i suppose
that means this one's defect is his sas
gene being turned all the way up these
benches i suggest you keep
moving okay so now the other clone gets
to make a wisdom saving throw against
hunter spell save which should be very
boring considering they're the same
person
that's it i know animation studios cut
costs by reusing animation but does
disney even realize that they use the
same character model for all of these
troopers
cheapskates i am
four six four az345-21189-624649 eight
seven two one three four seven
that's not a name that's a youtube link
guess i didn't find that mess whole
fight amusing
oh but i sure did honestly by this point
i'm surprised they named the character
wrecker instead of just big guys or dumb
and brutish cliche
jones where do you think you're going
the training facility is that way
training facility with their ability to
speak instantly to each other you'd
think someone would have been able to
tell them where to go without depending
on the random encounter in the hallway
here i'll summarize the next six minutes
for you pew pew pew dive roll
scoot oh no nope we're good the end
switch to live
fire live rounds could damage my clones
and my facility but i've also got a
dozen or so fully functional live round
robots installed and at the ready
despite my misgivings cause
what the hell yolo baby why leap down
inside of those that are shooting at you
rather than oh i don't know exiting down
the back side of the tower out of the
enemy's line of sight
also you have as much cover up there as
you do on the ground in a much better
view of everything
why would you give that up it was over
crosshair you had the high ground
let us see where the loyalty of these
clones truly lies
so lucky for the plot that omega just
happens to walk around everywhere with
nala say all day even to super important
meetings we are not alone
he would think that tech would have seen
the heat signature of people sneaking up
on them pretty easily
but nope you saw guerrera trained by
captain rex and general skywalker to
fight for the republic
you're six foot two have a 35 inseam and
use colgate whitening toothpaste for
sensitive teeth
now that we've got all that out of the
way can we please get back to the story
all now displaced refugees
since palpatine unjustly appointed
himself
emperor the scene politics on for some
time in other words
yep it's a star wars show some people
may watch that and be impressed with
hunter's instincts and aim but the rest
of us are screaming
what if that had been a person the fifth
is
omega i confirmed my suspicions after
analyzing her dna while we were in the
infirmary
oh you mean that time you briefly walked
into the infirmary and walked back out a
moment later never once looking at
anything other than your friends for two
minutes
also basing all your assumptions on
genetic makeup do you even gattaca bro
and you waited until now to mention it
advance recon commando clone corporal ct
1409 would be echo celente at tv sins
people will hear us don't worry omega
the scriptwriters already know where you
are
it's the only way to explain how when
you need to overhear important
information
you just happen to be tied to knowledge
hip but when the plot needs you alone
you're free to wander
throw them in the bridge and make sure
they're all in the same room so they can
do some more character work and team
building escape exercises
oh and make sure it's the same cell
omega is already in we're already an
hour in and we need to get this finale
moving you know what you should work on
explaining when you went soft that's not
how you fix that problem discount
deadshot the pressure just makes it
worse
i've got it why didn't i think of it
before because it would have been weird
to have this revelation five minutes
into the show
when you were taking out droids fits
here better get to the console and hit
the lever to lower the race shield
she's climbing into a wall do you know
how many assumptions you have to make to
think that she can get from that wall to
that switch
all of them you have to make all the
assumptions
do tv shows not know how helmets work
asking for a youtube channel
sir someone's overriding the controls
what if not
lion king's nala wanted to help aren't
there a million things she could have
done before now
and how does she know they needed her
right now and why does her tablet have
bay door controls
deus ex manala doesn't even begin to
cover it strap in kit
hunter then avoids strapping himself in
before the ship takes off at hyper speed
come on hunter kids learn by example
they learn it by watching you
okay
i am most commonly known as a borrowed
ladder
a degenerate did you know that we create
monthly exclusive videos for our city
club members bonus outtakes i don't know
peter meth is a hell of a drug
extra sins videos strange things are a
foot at the circle
k and even member chosen sin
commentaries
i love this i love this this kind of
of a sin because it's just it's so silly
pick our next video and see the
exclusives at patreon.com
cinemasins or click the link in the
description below spiderman is not a
parade you do not need to stop traffic
for spiders
hey kid you ready for this
we move fast speed i
am speed stay back
stay back you should know if you come
any closer
and not let you go they manipulated
pre-existing aberrations in our dna
resulting in your brute strength cross
has sharp shooting skills
hunter's enhanced senses and my
exceptional mind
so that's it what we some kind of
suicide squad
she is my medical assistant mother
what's a
long neck like that's what we all do
hello ct1409 his name is echo
what that's what we should call it echo
your name
is echo there's nothing missing in our
lives back home
we're here to make a difference we
believe all lives are special
some live some no she's one of us
i know it's not your fault
it's not your fault you know
it's not your fault
i know no no you don't it's not your
fault
i know it's not your fault all right
it's not your fault
it's not your fault